(swooshes)
- Failure is a stepping stone to success.
- Fail your way to success.
- Failure.
- Failure is a part of
the learning process.
- Success is moving from
one failure to the next.
- To get past your failure, you've got
to go through the failure.
- Success is merely the
hangover of failure.
- You should seek failures.
- Learn from those
mistakes, and get smarter.
- Hello, Believe Nation,
my name is Evan Carmichael.
My one word is believe, and I believe
that entrepreneurs are going to solve
all the major problems of the world.
So to help you on your journey, today,
we're going to learn how you
can turn failure into success.
And as always, guys, if you hear something
that really resonates with you,
please leave it down
in the comments below.
Put quotes around it, so other people
can be inspired as well,
and when you write it down,
it's much more likely to
stick for yourself, too.
Enjoy.
(bright hopeful music)
- Failure is part of life.
- Yeah.
- I mean, the difference for me, though,
I look at failure as a
stepping stone to success.
It's a speed bump.
I know I'm going to fail,
but it's not failure
if you learn something, and so, gosh,
I've made so many mistakes.
I've screwed so many things up,
but every time I do, it just becomes,
it becomes a way for me
to explain to someone else
what it takes, you know.
It's like, here's what I've done.
I think I have the ability
to influence people
because I like, talk about my failures.
I talk about all the
things that mess me up,
but I show people I didn't let it stop me,
and you don't need to let it stop you.
I think that's really
the secret in that area.
- And if everything you
touched was successful,
you probably wouldn't be able
to relate to people as much.
- No, you wouldn't be able to relate,
and also, it'd be total bull--
- Right.
- And everyone will know it's bull,
and also you'd be bored silly.
- Right.
- I mean, think about it.
If you just said, I want
this, and it happened.
I want this, and it happened.
You know, people don't value
what they don't fight for.
You know, it's like
you see kids sometimes.
You know, your parent's will say,
you're not going to value
this if you don't work for it.
And you're kid's goin', I'll value it.
Just give it to me.
(laughs)
It's true.
- Yeah.
- You know, about things
we we work the hardest for,
we value the most, so I think, you know,
the purpose of the goal's
not getting it anyway.
The purpose of the goal,
you know, is who you become.
Who you become is going to make you happy
or is going to make you sad.
- Yeah.
- So I'm not looking for
an effortless approach.
- Sure, sure, sure, sure.
- There's no such thing.
- If you constantly remind
yourself after every defeat,
after every setback, every
time you get knocked down,
I've got a saying.
If like knocks you down,
try and land on your back
because if you look up, you can get up.
See, a lot of people because
of failure, they stop.
They stop believing.
Let me share something with you.
You will fail your way to success.
Yes.
Eight out of 10 millionaires
have been financially bankrupt.
You will fail your way to success.
It doesn't matter how many times you fail.
It doesn't matter how
many times people tell you
that you can't do it.
It doesn't matter if you
don't have a dime in the bank.
You will fail your way to success.
- I've learned more from
failures than success.
And it can be paralyzing, this
failure and the fear of it.
My first album I made was a
album called Reasonable Doubt,
which in the small circles
was considered the album,
like a classic album, like
the album for that generation
and the voice of, you know, people
that were going through situations.
But it didn't sell massive
numbers worldwide, right.
It was still very niche.
My second album, because of,
you know, Reasonable Doubt,
and it's lack of commercial
success, you know,
I try to make these
records that were bigger
and will be more popular,
which was a failure.
Going for that success really
messed up that project,
and, you know, set a bad tone.
It was a huge learning lesson for me
that if I was going to be successful,
I had to be successful as myself.
I couldn't be successful doing
what other people were doing.
I had to do what I believed
in and what felt real to me
and felt true to me.
- Failure is a part of the
learning process, right?
What's the risk of failure?
What, you'll be embarrassed?
Or risk of failure, how do you
distinguish failure from learning?
In your whole life, you
know, failure implies
that it stops, the game stops, right?
If it's part of your
failing, and then you learn,
then, that learning is
part of the moving forward,
so that is what the process is like.
Fail, learn, move forward,
and constantly do that
because you're cutting edge.
You're going where people
haven't been before in inventiveness.
- If you say, I'm a fraud.
They'll figure me out.
I'll never be able to do it again.
That's an artist's thought process.
You're an artist.
(laughs)
If you're thinking like that,
you're on the right track
cause they all feel that way.
So there's always some
success that can come out
even out of your failures.
In fact, probably your
biggest successes will come
directly from your failures.
You should almost take that
Winston Churchill's quote
is my favorite, "Success
is moving from one
"failure to the next
with great enthusiasm."
You should be very enthusiastic
about your failures
cause you're going to learn something.
You're going to go that
way when everyone else
is going that way, and
you're going to stumble,
but you're also going to stumble upon
something that no one else thought of.
- Yeah.
- You just keep going and keep going.
And you're going to fail and
then rise up and fail again,
and that's the journey.
Up and down, man.
- You don't make excuses for the failure.
You grieve it.
You feel the pain.
You don't brush it off.
You don't downplay it.
You feel the pain, and you
don't rush to feel better.
Now, listen, this is a principle of life
I'm about to tell you.
To get past it, you got to go through it.
That's true in so many areas,
but it's particularly true with failure.
To get past your failure,
that failure in your life,
you got to go through it.
You cannot go around your failure.
You can't go over your failure.
You can't go under your failure.
You can't ignore your failure.
You need to grieve the failure.
You need to feel the pain.
Now, we don't like feeling
bad, but grief is a good thing.
Grief is the way we get
through the failure,
and grief is the way we learn the lessons.
So often we want to just, when we fail,
we want to just forget it.
Push it aside.
Stuff our emotions.
And then, immediately
go to the next thing.
When you stuff your
emotions, when you swallow
your emotions, your stomach keeps score.
It's kind of like, what
if you took a can of Coke,
and you shook it up for a long time,
and then you put it in the freezer?
What's going to happen to it?
It's going to explode eventually.
It's going to come out sideways.
And this happens in your
life when you don't deal
with your emotions properly.
This is why sometimes
six months after failure,
a marriage falls apart.
Or six months after
somebody gets laid off work,
there's another problem.
There's a physical health
problem, things like this,
because you've shaken up the can,
and you've got all these
emotions, feeling inside,
of shame and regret
and fear and insecurity
and all the things that come with failure.
And you're not dealing with 'em,
and so you shake it up and say, we're just
going to put this in the
refrigerator and try to forget
about it and we're going to freeze it.
And it's going to explode, and
it's going to come out sideways
in an affair or in wrong behavior
or in impulsivity or in addiction
or all kinds of other things.
I've seen this thousands
of times in people's lives.
You don't minimize it.
You don't rush to feel better.
To get past your failure, you've got to
go through the failure.
- You know, and my mentality is like,
I have a I don't lose mentality,
and that's with anything.
That's not like say, a
sporting event or whatever.
That's just life, right,
because life is non-stop tests.
You know what I mean?
And we're always being put to the test.
There's always challenges,
obstacles, et cetera,
and I literally don't accept any of that
as an impediment, as a negative.
It's like, good, this is
going to make me stronger.
I'm going to learn something from this.
- I think the best advice
that I could give you
on success is to know that success
is merely the hangover of failure.
And that failure is an
essential ingredient
in creating a learning atmosphere for you
so that you can accrue those learnings,
those small incremental steps of failure
and collect enough learning so that
you can arrive at success, right?
I think we're taught in
the system that failure
is something that you
should be ashamed of.
Failure is for the dumb kids
cause you get an F or you get a D, right.
You're not competent.
You didn't comply.
You didn't create the
evidence of your worthiness.
But I could tell you someone
who is successful, right,
both financially and
from a wealth creation
point of view, but more
importantly, a wealth that matters.
That success doesn't look like an A plus.
It doesn't look like 110 in extra credit.
And failure isn't as simple as an F.
And it's not always, like
failure can be very gray, right?
And being able to discern
what you might arrive
at an event in your life where you think
that wow, I've succeeded.
And you're getting the affirmation
from all these outside forces.
But if it's not aligned
authentically to who
and what you are, it could
very much feel like failure.
- You're going to fail.
It's okay.
Okay?
You're going to fail.
And I'm not talkin' about the tests.
That's one thing.
I'm talkin' about to your
knees, your skin bloody.
Fail.
And that's okay cause you know what?
You know down deep inside of all of you,
that's how you learn.
You need to be motivated by failure.
How'd you learn how to walk?
You crawled, and you fell down.
Busted your tooth.
Got some blood in your mouth.
Get up, and you walk.
Right?
Self-directed.
- You should seek failures.
See, if you're playing it
safe, you're not going to win.
If you're playing it safe,
like that old saying,
you know, you were taught
when you were a little girl.
Better to be safe than sorry.
Well, that's a bunch of crap.
It's not better to be safe than sorry.
It's by trying things that you figure out
how far you can go.
You got to get outside the box.
Like, it's reported
Edison tried 3,000 ways
before he built the incandescent light.
He said he didn't fail 3,000 times.
He said there was 3,000 different steps
to building a light bulb.
Well, there's different steps
to get to where you're going.
And I really do treat winning
and losing exactly the same.
I do not let it upset me.
- Do you think that's a big part
of why you're so successful?
- Well, it's part of why I enjoy it.
Yeah, I think it is
cause I'll try anything.
Like, if I'm into an
idea, the idea of losing
never enters my mind.
See, I have worked with giants.
I had the good fortune of working
with Sir Edmund Hillary.
He was the first man to
stand on top of the world.
And I worked with him on
three different occasions.
And the only difference in
Ed Hillary and Bob Proctor
is in his size.
Now, he's gone now, but he was big man.
When he shook hands with
me, his hand wrapped
right around mine.
I felt like a dwarf, you know.
And in talking to him,
it never entered his mind
he wouldn't get to the
top of the mountain,
but he failed in 1951.
He failed in 1952.
It wasn't until 1953 that he
got to the top of the mountain.
You know, people had died for
centuries trying to do that.
But he said, I knew if
I could see it in here,
I could hold it out here.
Stella Mann wrote that in a book.
If you can see it in your head,
you can hold it in your hand.
And that's right.
And if you're not prepared to
lose, you're never going to win.
Cause you're always playing it safe,
and there's no reward in that.
- You know, I'm a woman in the business.
- [Lori] That's right.
- So are you, and it's
great because there are
different personalities, successful.
Be yourself.
Take care of business.
- Be yourself.
- Go for it.
- Yes.
- Get out there.
But it can be bumpy along the way.
Any regrets or mistakes that you feel
you've kind of hit through the years?
- Well, you know, I share certain bumps
that I've had in the book.
I think that, you know, I
don't like to look back.
There are no mistakes really.
Everything is a learning lesson.
Everything helps you to do better.
- [Queen Latifah] Right.
- I talk about some of
the mistakes that I made,
and it just helps you
to get further along.
Learn from those
mistakes, and get smarter.
- Thank you guys so much for watching.
I hope you enjoyed.
I'd love to know what was
your biggest take-away
from this video?
What are you going to immediately apply
somehow to your life or to your business?
Leave it down in the comments below.
I'm super curious to find out.
I also want to give a quick shout-out
to Wesley Lavinder from
fullyoptimized.org.
Wesley, thank you so much for picking up
a copy of my book Your One Word.
It really, really means a lot to me,
and I hope you're enjoying the read.
So thank you guys again for watching.
I believe in you.
I hope you continue to
believe in yourself,
and whatever your one word is, much love.
I'll see you soon.
(swooshes)